i think she would feel very angry with
how this is panned out
and very sad during prince harry and
meghan markle's 90-minute
interview with oprah winfrey the couple
opened up about his late mother princess
diana
and how she influenced their decision to
step back as senior members of the royal
family
and what i was seeing was history
repeating itself but more perhaps
or definitely far more dangerous because
then you add racing
and you add social media in and when i'm
talking about history opinions
i'm talking about my my mother harry i
think the backdrop of everything is
constantly remembering
the things that his mother went through
he lived through that he witnessed it
but
at his age and in his position he was
unable to protect
from it so you can totally understand
why he would want to then put the shield
up for megan and his family to make sure
that they don't suffer
that same tragic fate princess diana
died in 1997
in a car accident in paris while being
chased by the paparazzi
following her own exit from the royal
family now prince harry says
all the negative media attention made
him fear for his
own family's safety following his 2018
wedding
and the 2019 birth of his son archie
when you can see something happening
in the same kind of way
anybody would ask for help ask the
system of which you are part of
especially when you know there's a
relationship there that they could
help and share some truth or call the
dogs off whatever you want to call it
so to receive no help at all and to be
told continuously
this is how it is this is just how it is
we've all been through it
harry understands this very complex
world
where his family members are also
employees or representatives of the
institution of the monarchy
and so there are times where the queen
is wearing the crown and she is not his
grandmother
and she has to act simply for the
purposes of the crown
she's a woman that has always said that
she puts duty first
and that duty comes before family it's
why harry harry's often found himself at
odds with certain family members
including his brother
who do put duty first because harry
picked family first
diana separated from prince charles in
1992
and officially filed for divorce in 1996
losing her hrh title in the process
like harry and megan she famously went
public with her side of the story in a
televised interview with martin beshear
in 1995. at the age of 19
you always think you're prepared for
everything and you think you have the
knowledge of what's coming ahead
but although i was daunted at the
prospect at the time i felt i had the
support of my husband to be
i desperately wanted to work i i
desperately loved my husband
and i wanted to share everything
together and i thought
that we were a very good team people
were also quick to point out the
similarities between diana's interview
and megan's interview both ladies wore
dark ensembles with dark eye makeup
and both discussed their highly
publicized struggles with the royal
family
and intimate details of their
experiences the media were everywhere
and here was a fairy story that
everybody wanted to work
and so it was
it was isolating but it was also
a situation where you couldn't indulge
in feeling sorry for yourself you had to
either sink
or swim and you had to learn that very
fast
and what did you do i swam we always
heard diana talking about the men in
grey suits
but we didn't really get to hear what it
is that they were capable of
and so to see harry and megan really
suffer the hands of some of that
you know with the stories that were
leaked to the press but the games that
went on behind the scenes
you know net i would like to think that
people had a better idea of what it was
that they're up against but
listen sunday is going to fill in all
the gaps they're gonna be able to tell
that story for themselves for the first
time
during the sit-down megan also paid
tribute to her late mother-in-law by
wearing her diamond tennis bracelet
what do you think your mom would say
about this stepping back this decision
to step back from the royal family how
would she feel about this moment i think
she would feel very angry
with how this is panned out and very sad
but ultimately all she'd
all she'd ever want is for us to be
happy harry noted that though the
process has been tough
he's relieved to have gone through his
exit from the royal family with his wife
by his side
i'm just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago because it has been
unbelievably tough for the two of us but
at least we had each other